there's several things in the news right
now where people that have a sense of
entitlement they feel like they are do
something are quote having their say
obviously the Occupy Wall Street folks
fall into that category the the same
folks same group of folks are the ones
that are saying if I work at McDonald's
I'm you $15 an hour and we're gonna head
to a fast-food strike the wealth
equality movement has at its core a
entitlement mentality because I'm
entitled to have the same level of
wealth as you you're not special you've
not worked harder you're not smarter
you're not more talented than me and so
I'm due to have exactly the same amount
of wealth that you have and it's unfair
that you have more than I am all of
those have at its core this entitlement
thing and this entitlement thing is
raising up in our culture and for those
of us that are on the opposite end of
the spectrum it's pretty disturbing to
us because it it smacks of a lack of
personal responsibility it smacks of a
lack of initiative it says that somehow
that the only way to fix things is a
governmental fix which would be
communism basically taking over all of
our assets and thereby redistributing
them to the entitled ones that don't
have the assets and haven't done
anything to earn the assets so this
entitlement spirit is a disturbing
spirits I've been thinking about it
because in light of the smart money
smart kids book and all the speaking
we've been doing on teaching kids how to
handle money I'm thinking about where
does the spirit come from and really
what is the antidote to it because I got
to tell you it's highly unattractive I
mean the idea that you're do something
that you didn't do anything to get that
you look up in your own third base and
somebody sent you there and you feel
like you hit a triple is an unattractive
character quality highly unattractive
so why would we ever want our kids to
have this mentality because in the
marketplace they're not marketable in
the marketplace people don't reward this
I'm do something even though I haven't
done anything to get that thing
mentality it's attractive I think the
opposite of it is probably gratitude
there's an arrogance to entitlement and
there is a sense of humility gratitude
gratitude says thank you thank you for
being my customer thank you for allowing
me to serve your table thank you for
giving me a job that allows me to feed
my family and buy electricity for my
kids and heating and cooling for our
home thank you for working for me and
working with me on my team and I'm going
to say thank you by the way I pay you
and the way the things I do for you if
you're one of my team members working on
my team thank you thank you Lord for the
blessings that you poured into my life
thank you as an incredible expression of
gratitude and I got to tell you it's
highly attractive think about a child in
your presence that doubles up their
fists and his red-faced and acts like
they deserve something
has a little temper fit versus the child
that smiles and says thank you for what
you've done for me thank you for this
gift thank you for this birthday gift
not having a fancy fit because the cake
is the wrong color and we've got a whole
culture that's having a hissy fit
because their cake at their birthday is
the wrong color because they think the
axis of the world runs through the
center of their head so entitlement has
Addis essence this sense of arrogance so
how do we combat that well as I said in
the corner of at the core of gratitude
is a sense of humility versus arrogance
and so it starts with humility and
humility can then lead to gratitude and
humility is not humiliation humility is
I understand my place I understand that
if I don't do something nothing's going
to happen
humility then can lead to gratitude and
by the way gratitude can lead to
contentment but you will never find
someone who is entitled who is content
think about that that's a little bit
profound if you work your way through it
and and so this idea of what we want to
teach our children are who we want to be
as people is I want to start with a
sense of humility
now humility is not I think less of
myself that's false humility humility is
CS Lewis said I think less of not I
think less of myself it's I think of
myself less I'm not was worried about me
it's not all about me that's a sense of
humility and so we need to work on that
ourselves we need to definitely have our
kids begin to understand that concept
which leads them to the ability to be
grad grateful because again if you want
to be a highly attractive human being be
a grateful human being